you're working in australia so what what  are you working on  i am working on baslerman's uh movie  about elvis presley austin butler is  playing elvis presley and here let me  show you  let me show you the horrible haircut i  have to have  in order to portray colonel tom parker  check out check out this horrible okay  do you see that  look at that thing wait wait wait sit  [Applause]  [Music]  down  [Applause]  [Laughter]  what i really want to do is just have a  little tuft of hair right here  and then a big big beard and then  everybody would think i'm graham norton  yes it's uncanny you can play me in the  biopic  well now i i'm evidently that's my gig  now so i only play real people in show  [Music]  business